[Música]
contundente rechazo internacional por
parte de la unión europea eeuu y varios
países latinoamericanos a las elecciones
parlamentarias en venezuela donde la
abstención se situó por encima del 70%
del chavismo llegó nuevamente al poder
legislativo tenemos reportes de caracas
continúan estancadas las conversaciones
entre unión europea y reino unido- para
la relación post praxis los líderes
británicos y el bloque comunitario no
lograron reducir las diferencias por lo
que la presidenta de la comisión europea
y el primer ministro británico acordaron
reunirse de forma presencial en bruselas
tenemos reportes desde lonjas
el ex presidente francés nicolas sarkozy
negó todas las acusaciones en su contra
en su histórico juicio por corrupción
sarkozy prometió ir hasta el final para
limpiar su nombre tenemos información
desde la capital francesa
muy buenas noches gracias por continuar
con nosotros en france 24 se hablan con
gusto saludarlos comenzamos a este
informativo en venezuela donde crece el
número de países que rechazan los
resultados de las elecciones
legislativas celebradas este domingo ya
son casi 50 los que no reconocen el
triunfo del chavismo en américa el
bloque más grande que ha dicho hasta el
momento desconocer el resultado de la
votación lo constituyen 16 países que
van desde canadá pasando por el salvador
guatemala guyana haití honduras panamá
paraguay perú república dominicana
colombia ecuador costa rica de chile
en eeuu el secretario de estado- mike
campeó pidió a sus aliados que sigan
reconociendo como presidente interino a
juan guaidó y por su parte la unión
europea pidió la celebración en
venezuela- de elecciones transparentes
pero vamos hasta caracas la capital
venezolana con nuestra corresponsal
herminia fernández ervin ya muy buena
noche que empezó a hacer la oposición
una vez que la asamblea nacional está
ahora en manos del gobierno
si debo estar noche raúl todo el día de
hoy luego decir juan guaidó y los países
los perdonen partidos que lo apoyan que
fue una derrota en la elección del día
de ayer para el gobierno a nicolás
maduro comenzó su consulta muscular que
viene organizando desde hace algunas
semanas hoy fue de manera online y será
hasta el 12 de diciembre la gente puede
votar por la página web por una
aplicación y por un canal de tele pero
es se supone que el día 12 en 78 países
y en 335 municipios de venezuela sa
población está de votación de manera
presencial se trata de que los
venezolanos pueden votar a tres
preguntas una tiene que ver con las
elecciones pedir una nueva elección
libre presidencial otra tiene que ver
con rechazar las elecciones
parlamentarias del día de ayer y una
última pidiendo ayuda humanitaria la
idea es entregar estos resultados al
final a la comunidad internacional para
que ellos sigan presionando al gobierno
de nicolás maduro
herminia estas elecciones se celebraron
con más del 70% de abstención le
pregunto que ha dicho el gobierno de
maduro sobre esto
si la última cifra se conoce así que
regresó en el consejo nacional electoral
emitiera su final y transmisión de cerca
un 98 por ciento la transmisión y si es
un 30 50 por ciento como dices tú casi
70 por ciento el diputado electo horner
los días por el gran polo patriótico que
es el grupo de partidos del gobierno
señaló en rueda de prensa que llegó o
trató más bien de minimizar esta
extensión diciendo que se debió al kobe
19 y a las sanciones que hay puestos
distintos países a venezuela también
dijo jorge rodríguez que momento de que
el pueblo fue el que triunfó porque él
pidió una nueva asamblea nacional y
pidió a toda esa comunidad internacional
que está según ellos agobiando a su
gobierno que dejen de imponer sanciones
y bloqueos también hizo un llamado a los
diputados que fueron elegidos para que
comiencen a apoyar ya crear nuevas leyes
que mejoren la economía de venezuela
herminia gracias por la información de
herminia fernández corresponsal de
france 24 en caracas continuamos las
conversaciones entre la unión europea
y reino unido continúan bloqueados la
presidenta de la comisión europea úrsula
von der layen y el primer ministro
británico boris johnson acordaron
durante una conversación telefónica
reunirse de forma presencial en bruselas
para abordar la negociación sobre la
relación comercial futura tras el
divorcio en londres nuestra corresponsal
luisa pulido con los detalles
es bien significativo que para poder
destrabar estas negociaciones que están
enredadas hace varios meses la
presidenta de la comisión europea y
boris johnson hayan acordado que deben
reunirse personalmente esto debe ser
antes del jueves porque se reunirán los
líderes de la unión europea para su
última cumbre del año no se sabe que
pueden acordar estos dos líderes en una
conversación personal que no se haya
podido conseguir en varias llamadas
telefónicas de varias horas alguno de
los dos tendrá que ceder en estas líneas
rojas tres puntos muy complejos
especialmente derechos de pesca si
quieren conseguir el acuerdo sobre sí
del acuerdo de la futura relación entre
las partes para dar más dramatismo a
esta noche el parlamento británico
aprobó por una aplastante mayoría un
poder una ley que le da al gobierno la
potestad de romper la ley internacional
de romper el acuerdo de retirada
'breaks' y sin embargo si el primer
ministro así lo desea puede en este
trámite legislativo que la ley va a
seguir teniendo durante esta semana
retirarlo pero esta es una estrategia de
negociación de orgulloso un as bajo la
manga que sabe que puede utilizar para
obtener el mejor
acuerdo de retirada posible frente a
europa especialmente en derechos de
pesca
y cambiamos nuevamente de información
pero seguimos en reino unido donde las
autoridades empiezan mañana su programa
de vacunación contra el cob y 19 el
mayor de su historia después de
convertirse la semana pasada en el
primer país del mundo en aprobar el uso
de la vacuna de first the fighter en
bayonne tec el ministro de sanidad matan
con confirmó que todas las regiones del
territorio británico han recibido ya una
parte proporcional de las 800.000 dosis
iniciales que se ofrecerán en esta
primera fase a los grupos más
vulnerables de la población comenzando
por los mayores de 80 años de edad
y vamos hasta rusia donde el sábado
comenzó la vacunación contra el virus
los trabajadores con alto riesgo de
contagiarse de la enfermedad empezaron a
recibir esta vacuna al sputnik 5 que
tendría el 95 por ciento de efectividad
según las autoridades rusas en total
sólo en moscú se han abierto 70 centros
de vacunación inicialmente para los
trabajadores sociales personal médico y
también maestros quienes no podrán
consumir bebidas alcohólicas por 42 días
para así evitar cualquier tipo de efecto
adverso sin embargo el kremlin dijo que
se mantendrán las festividades de fin de
año
continuamos en europa el ex presidente
francés nicolas sarkozy testificó este
lunes ante el tribunal que le juzga por
corrupción y tráfico de influencias
delitos que negó al tiempo que atacó a
la fiscalía nacional financiera a la que
acusó de tejer contra él una persecución
desde su salida del icio durante más de
tres horas el hombre que dirigió francia
entre 2007 y 2012 desestimó las
acusaciones sacadas a la luz o tras las
conversaciones mantenidas con su abogado
thierry herzog
a través de un teléfono intervenido por
la policía en otra investigación de la
financiación de libia de su compañía
electoral nuestra periodista en parís
ser igual a barría estuvo en la
audiencia y tiene más detalles
con tres horas de retardo comenzó la
locución del ex presidente nicolas
sarkozy antes tuvimos que escuchar la
lectura de la transcripción de algunas
de las conversaciones que fueron
grabadas entre él y su abogado y que son
la principal prueba en su contra en este
caso en que es acusado de corrupción
activa y de tráfico de influencias
justamente en esos textos se puede leer
como sarkozy y su abogado hablaban de un
posible cargo para el juez así ver en
mónaco y como al final parecía
arrepentirse de lo mismo fue el momento
de hablar de nicolas sarkozy que se
mantenía muy ansioso por dirigirse a la
presidenta de la corte se movía
gesticulaba y manipula una carpeta azul
y volvió a acusar de infamias dijo hace
seis años que me persiguen con infamias
y juro que nunca ha mentido y que nunca
ha cometido corrupción dijo no entiendo
por qué me pasa esto a mí porque fui
presidente de la república y dijo en
algunos momentos creer que la justicia
económica había sido creada para él dada
la cantidad de causas en su contra que
se acumularon en
un momento
y seguimos en francia que despliega la
alfombra roja para el presidente egipcio
por segunda vez en tres años una visita
de tres días que prevé una oportunidad
para arreglar las relaciones el
presidente del fatal si si no quedó
feliz con el hecho de que manuel macro
no le cuestionara por los derechos
humanos el año pasado veamos
en 2017 abdel fattah al sisi conoció por
primera vez a de manuel majo elegido
cinco meses atrás más como fue hablando
con el presidente egipcio negándose a
criticarlo frente a la prensa
especialmente sobre los problemas de
derechos humanos de una mención que la
automoción es de otros líderes sobre
cómo liderar así como tampoco me doy
lecciones a mí mismo
al tiempo varias ongs condenaban la peor
crisis de derechos humanos en egipto en
décadas señalando detenciones masivas
sentencias a muerte y torturas
extendidas sin embargo egipto es útil
para francia en la región en su lucha
contra el terrorismo además el país galo
se ha convertido en uno de los
principales proveedores de armamento de
los egipcios
francia ha vendido equipos militares y
de vigilancia a egipto durante varios
años
[Música]
nuestros reportes muestran como las
autoridades egipcias han usado este
material para reprimir a los
manifestantes
hugo redime de manifestación en enero de
emanuel pajón fue al cairo donde
inesperadamente sí planteó cuestiones
sobre los derechos humanos lo que
disgustó al sitio ahora en esta nueva
visita el presidente francés parece
volver a su posición original tan
criticada por defensores de derechos
humanos yo en condiciones de para no
condicionar en nuestra cooperación en
defensa y economía a esos desacuerdos
primero porque creo en la soberanía
nacional y al respeto por nuestro
interés legítimo y recíproco
porque creo que es más eficiente tener
una política que demande diálogo a una
política del boicot lo que reduciría la
efectividad de nuestro socio en la lucha
contra el terrorismo y la estabilidad
regional o stability regional
sería en efectivo en materia de derechos
humanos y contraproducente en la lucha
terrorismo último abismo justo antes de
la llegada de al sisi a parís el domingo
egipto liberó a tres trabajadores
humanitarios se estima que 60 mil
detenidos en egipto son prisioneros
políticos
en rumanía un día después de las
elecciones legislativas comienzan las
negociaciones para formar gobierno el
primer ministro conservador lidové orbán
dimitió para que su partido pueda seguir
gobernando en coalición con los
centristas los socialdemócratas
vencieron los comicios pero no tienen
los apoyos suficientes para recuperar el
gobierno arrebatado por orbán en moción
de censura en 2019 informados muñoz
continúa la inestabilidad en rumanía las
elecciones legislativas del domingo 6 de
noviembre acabaron con el gobierno del
conservador ludovic orbán cuyo partido
perdió frente al socialdemócrata unos
comicios en los que los rumanos han
castigado la gestión de la pandemia
tome hoy la decisión de renunciar al
cargo de primer ministro la decisión que
tome es la consecuencia de la voluntad
del pueblo para que comiencen
negociaciones para formar un nuevo
gobierno
sin embargo no parece que los
socialdemócratas vayan a gobernar puesto
que al ser rumanía un sistema
parlamentario se necesitan mayorías el
pnl del dimitido orbán busca apoyo en el
centrista usb plus
quien había exigido la renuncia del
líder para formar gobierno sin embargo
ambos necesitarán a un tercer partido lo
que complica unas negociaciones en las
que confía el presidente del país se
cristaliza
una coalición de centroderecha está
tomando forma rápidamente y podrá
proponer un gobierno de coalición en los
próximos días iniciará consultas con los
partidos que estarán en el nuevo
basile
en octubre de 2019 ludovic orbán llegó
al poder mediante una moción de censura
que acabó con el gobierno
socialdemócrata en febrero los
socialdemócratas estuvieron a punto de
conseguir vengarse pero no lograron
llevar a cabo su moción de censura
finalmente han sido las urnas las que
han terminado con el periodo de orbán
aunque el pnl es el favorito para
continuar gobernando con el objetivo de
dar por fin a estabilidad al país
y las urnas cerraron en las elecciones
presidenciales de ghana luego de que los
ciudadanos votaran en lo que se espera
sea una contienda reñida entre el
presidente de nana akufo addo y su
principal rival john mamá los ojos están
puestos en la potencia de áfrica
occidental para ver si puede mantener su
posición como bastión de la democracia
en la región inestable donde las
disputas electorales de este año han
avivado los temores de un retroceso
hacia el autoritarismo
y san gregorio armeno ar - en nápoles
conocido mundialmente por la excelencia
en términos de figurillas y artesanías
de la navidad dedico su apertura el
lunes al fallecido futbolista diego
armando maradona luego de varias semanas
de cierre por las restricciones del coi
19 el hermano de maradona hugo cortó la
cinta para inaugurar la reapertura de la
famosa calle antes de la temporada
navideña
bob dylan leyenda de la música rock y
también premio nobel de literatura
vendió los derechos de todo su catálogo
musical que engloba más de 60 años hay
universal music
[Música]
el acuerdo incluye más de 600 canciones
del músico y los medios de comunicación
de eeuu señalan que su repertorio podría
ser valorado en 300 millones de dólares
con música despedimos el informativo con
todas las cosas
[Música]